hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
James Rachel's in his classic analysis
the challenges of cultural relativism
sets out and isolates five sets of
claims that he takes to be really at the
heart of any formulation of cultural
relativism and he reviews quite a few of
them so I'm coming from anthropologist
so have some coming from our general
Western culture in late modernity and
each of these he sets out so that we can
look at them in turn and see whether
they're actually plausible
so first let's see what each of them is
and then talk a little bit about their
implications what the meaning of them
would be Rachel's own viewpoint on their
interdependence or contradiction and
then some of the rejoinders or
qualifications that he thinks are
important to set out in this piece so
the first is quite simple different
societies have different moral codes the
second the moral code of a society
determines what is right in that society
he actually adds a little bit to that
that is if the moral code of a society
a certain action is right that action is
right at least within that society the
third is there is no objective standard
that can be used to judge one society's
code as better than another's there's no
moral truths that hold for all people at
all time the fourth the moral code of
our own society has no special status it
is but one among many then fifth and
finally it is arrogant for us to judge
other cultures we should always be
tolerant of them so now let's look at
each of these a little bit more closely
different societies have different moral
codes this is supposed to be not so much
a normative statement but a descriptive
statement telling us about how judgments
and evaluations are made about moral
matters within those societies and
rachels gives you several now classic
examples one from Herodotus where the
Greeks are told that you know somebody's
proposing for them to eat their dead and
another group of people are told that
the proposal is that they should burn
their dead and both of them recoil in
horror from what the other group /
supposedly do and this is supposed to
demonstrate to us that there are
different customs different deeply felt
and held beliefs and sentiments about
what's right and wrong and this is quite
true even within the same society we
often have incredible variance among
moral judgments don't we even people
within the same culture disagree about
what is right and wrong the second one
the moral code of a society determines
what is right in that society this is a
somewhat stronger claim if we're
understanding it merely in a descriptive
way then we could say the moral code of
a society - determines for the members
of the society or other people within
that
any trying to take part in it what
counts as right or wrong but this is
going a little bit further it's saying
right and wrong is actually determined
as such by what society that you're in
and it's sort of like you know Pascal's
observation that on this side of the
Pyrenees this is true and on this side
of the Pyrenees this is false different
sides of the Pyrenees of course being
France and Spain the third one there is
no objective standard to judge one
society's code as better than another
with the implication that there are no
moral truths that holds for all people
at all times again a very strong claim
there there's no way to say that one
code or even one portion of a code say
perhaps the parts that have to do with
how to bury or not bury or dispose of or
not dispose of the dead or how long one
should remain in mourning and what one
ought to wear or whether one ought to be
married and what marriage is going to
look like those would all be parts of
codes and then we can talk about the
totality of a cultures code as well this
is saying we cannot judge any of them in
relation to each other doesn't mean that
you can't judge within a particular
society that there would be better and
worse ways of doing things but that
would fall into the number-two category
wouldn't it you're already within that
society at that point the fourth is very
interesting this one is not going to
apply to all societies but to modern
Western industrialized liberal
democratic however whatever
qualifications we want to place on it
our society we should not try to say
that our moral code has any sort of
special status it is merely one among
many different possibilities no better
no
worse than any of them presumably the
moral code that we have today is no
better than the one that we had within
our society say in 1950 or 1850 or 1750
as well so that would be a bit of an
implication of that and then finally the
the probably the strongest claim of all
number five it is arrogant to judge
other cultures we should instead take an
attitude of tolerance towards all of
them this is what the cultural
relativist is telling us as again
members of modern liberal Western
democratic industrial or post-industrial
whatever we are society the cultural
relativist is typically not saying this
to everybody else although perhaps he or
she is thinking it in their mind in
their heart as they approach other
cultures which do not in fact without
your tolerance to the degree that that
we do or at least claim to now it's
quite interesting great shalls' points
out that these five propositions may
seem to go together but they're actually
independent of one another so you could
in fact believe number one without
believing number five or you could in
fact believe number three without
believing number two you could have any
of these together in a combination you
don't actually have to have all five
although he also points out there does
appear to be a bit of a contradiction
between some of them as well and he
gives the example the second says right
and wrong are determined by the norms of
a society the fifth says one should
always be tolerant of other cultures but
what do we do he says in the case of a
society whose norms include intolerance
and the example that he has quite
interestingly has to do with Nazi
Germany invading Poland now think this
through
he says that when the Nazi army invaded
Poland beginning World War two this was
an intolerant act of the
order but what if it conformed to Nazi
ideals you could say well that at the
core of Nazism was this view that races
have to struggle against each other this
is a good thing
who are we to condemn the Nazis who were
even the Polish people who are being
invaded to condemn the Nazi is coming in
rachels has another interesting twist to
this though he says well you know once
they cross that border into polish
society wouldn't they be bound by the
norms of Polish society rather than
their Nazi ideology I mean they are in a
way sort of like resident aliens albeit
within a military organization and so
shouldn't they have given up their
Nazism at the border this is kind of an
ingenious way of talking about this and
you notice that there are some internal
at least tensions if not contradictions
between some of these as well as rachel
is pointing out now towards the end of
his essay Rachel's also says we need to
take each of these and think about the
extent to which they are actually true
or correct or valid what qualifications
would we need to make in order to hold
on to these claims different societies
have different moral codes that is
unmistakeably true there are different
moral codes again I've pointed out even
within the same society subcultures
often vary from each other and
individuals vary from each other
however Rachel's points out this doesn't
mean that the codes are entirely
different from each other as a matter of
fact if you think about certain basic
human functions like say regulating
sexuality or regulating killing every
society every perspective that takes a
moral stand says it's okay to kill in
this case but not in this case and they
vary about what those cases are how to
draw the lines but they do recognize you
can't just kill anybody at any time or
take whatever you want or sleep with
whoever you want so there are
shared norms of some sort number two is
a little bit weaker the moral code of a
society determines what is right in that
society Rachael's points out that when
we assert that we're forgetting a
fundamental distinction the distinction
that every society pretty much
recognizes within its language in its
logic the distinction between believing
something to be the case and actually
being correct about that being the case
because that is true so it's quite
possible that societies could in fact be
mistaken about whether something is the
good thing to do or the right thing to
do or whether it's the wrong thing to do
if not there would be no possibility of
a society actually deciding to change
its norms from within or social conflict
over whether things are right or wrong
the third one no objective standard to
judge one society's code is better than
any other Rachel says well if that's the
case we're in real trouble because that
means that we're not going to be able to
condemn or even judge or probably even
successfully analyze certain cultural
practices that are widely recognized as
wrong and he uses the example of female
circumcision as a prime case we could
also think of genocide as another case
and what Rachel's suggests to us is if
we're going to be able to say that some
things are wrong it is important that
we're not just saying well they're wrong
because they don't fit the American Way
or something like that we're going to
need some what he calls principles that
are not tethered to particular societies
we're going to need something more like
say general moral principles of a
utilitarian oricon she enter some other
kind or a conception of moral rights or
even human rights and then you know
there can be some argument as people
have made that
our Western conceptions but you know the
West is a little bit broader than just a
single particular culture isn't it it's
kind of get it interesting quasi status
is something at least potentially
universal that we can put that aside for
the moment let's look at number four so
if we say that the moral code of our
society has no special status and that
there are many different ways of living
all of them equally valid then does that
actually mean that they're all equally
good it doesn't seem that we have to say
that they're all automatically on
exactly the same level and then finally
with the fifth one it's arrogant to
judge other cultures we should be
tolerant of them and Rachel's wants to
say it simply is not going to work to be
tolerant of everything and he says
there's much truth in this the point is
overstated we are often arrogant when we
criticize other cultures and tolerance
is gender generally a good thing but we
shouldn't tolerate everything and he
says if we want to actually make any
progress as human societies or if we
want to honor the progress that has been
made then we have to say that not
everything can be tolerated and a
general across-the-board
attitude of Tolerance is not actually
morally appropriate so these are the
five claims that Rachel's takes as being
central to most typical portrayal of
cultural relativism and I think he's
actually quite correct about that and
then we can see how each of these has to
be qualified if we want to hold on to
those claims
you